Oh,
I think it's been terrible.
Uh,
you know,
I think the whole embedding process was
a masterstroke of the Pentagon's,
a ability to sort of turn journalists
into cheerleaders and I'm a co op and he
sort of independent thinking it's very
hard as a journalist to go into a
conflict completely,
uh,
um,
fresh eyed when you've been through
training courses where you have to learn
to put on a gas mask and nine seconds
flat,
uh,
where you are traveling with US troops
and you're expecting to be gassed by
these terrible Iraqis at any moment and
people are shooting at you as you go
through a country and the people
protecting you with the ones that you're
supposed to be writing about as one
part.
Hopefully one part of a conflict.
And unfortunately the,
the,
um,
the coverage was very obviously one
sided because there was no access to any
other side.
And um,
and there was for a while,
you know,
when Baghdad fell and as it was falling,
a number of us left rm beds as quickly
as possible and tried to get out and
into a meet and live with a Iraqis in
Baghdad.
And,
and that,
that,
that happened for a number of months
before the kidnappings and the situation
in,
in Baghdad became so dangerous that
journalists will no longer able to go
out and freely report.
And so,
um,
once again,
we have a situation where most of the
news,
fresh news from journalists,
at least Western journalists in,
in,
uh,
in Iraq is being done from behind,
you know,
behind the lines of American troops.
And I'm with only feelers being sent out
for very quick runs into a,
you know,
the Iraqi.
I'm a residential area.